a new CBS News poll shows a majority of
Americans have a pessimistic outlook for
the environment 57% believe it will be
worse for the next generation only 12%
believe it will be better the new book
offers a more optimistic view of the
future of our environment it is called
climate of hope how cities businesses
and citizens can save the planet
the book is written by former New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg who was on
60 minutes last night and former Sierra
Club executive bird director Carl Polk
good morning good morning Lonnie I was
just 16 minutes experience it was great
anything on CBS is good we think that
too but it was very good so this is a
call to action and especially a call to
action at the local level yes because
people live in cities that's where the
problems are but that's also where the
solutions are federal government's move
money's around state governments moves
money's around but local governments
influence how we get around what fuels
we can burn whether or not we are
compliant with the rules and people who
want to live cleaner have breathe
cleaner air drink more pure water have a
better economy it's in the cities where
they can change things not too late it's
certainly not too late and the whole
idea of this book Carl and I got
together and said everybody's so
pessimistic but we really are making a
big difference we are going to meet the
cop21 goals without any help from the
federal government basically in fact the
United States has reduced its carbon
emissions by a larger ratio than any
other major industrial nation we've
already accomplished two-thirds of what
President Obama promised to accomplish
by 2025 and this is being driven by
public sentiment at the local level by
leaders from cities and by innovation by
American business but if you're talking
about the globe China and India are some
of the largest polluters on the globe
wait a second China in all fairness is
one of the countries that is working the
hardest to clean things up why because
you can't see across the streets the
pollution is so bad and they've woken up
and said we just are not going to stay
in power unless we do something and so
they are closing qualified power plans
they are closing cement plans they're
closing steel plants we're moving them
away from the cities and
yeah just announced that they will not
build anymore coal-fired power plants
for the next decade they put a complete
suspension on starting new coal-fired
power plants because in India right now
if you put out a bid solar comes in
first wind comes in second coal comes in
a poor third in terms of costs oh but
we're not at a point in which
alternative means of creating energy are
lower than fossil fuel leaner means
cheaper cheaper cleaner that's what
clean energies be you know what's
happened in Charlie with the jobs
unfortunately for people who work in the
coal industry technology is devastating
them back in 1925 there were 800,000
people that worked in coal in 1980 there
were 250,000 today this 55,000 and
production has gone up so it's all
technology that's destroying jobs and we
can't just sit here and say low blow be
hook to us or woe to the coal miners
we've got to do something and what you
have to do is help them train for other
jobs because those jobs aren't going to
come back but you have an administration
in Washington says it's gonna reduce the
standard from an EPA that it's gonna
withdraw from the Paris agreement well
hopefully that won't happen hopefully
they'll get some sense and say look
America is going to meet his goals
anyways it would send a bad message
let's go along and try to work from
within rather than from without but no
matter what they do we are going towards
the world where coal is going to be less
used where fewer people are going to be
working in the industry and we've got to
find a ways to get jobs for people who
are not just in this industry but in
lots of industries around the world
being pushed out by technology and you
don't do it by going and creating jobs
we don't need you have to create jobs we
need there's a good example is we have
lots of soldiers veterans we've got to
take care of them we got to find jobs
for veterans but you don't go start a
war to give them jobs you find things
that they can do and that we need in
society and there are ways to do that
and one of the things Bloomberg
philanthropies is working on is
supporting those kinds of organizations
we can you both say that you want to
start a new conversation about climate
change you said you don't want let's
talk about the immediate threat for so
many people it seems so far in the
distance and you're saying no don't put
the environment
the economy Karl well let's look at the
reality we didn't make America great by
keeping buggy flips going in the 1920s
we made America great by building the
world's greatest auto industry we're
building right now we have the
opportunity to build the world's
greatest clean energy industry we
developed the basic technology we have
the world's greatest electric cars we
ought to be embracing a future already
clean energy employs five times as many
people as natural gas coal and oil
combined so there are hundreds of
thousands of jobs in the clean energy
industry there can be millions and
cities are competing with each other to
see who can get the most of them that's
what's great about cities they compete
to move forward not to look backward in
jail to answer your question the problem
line is the air that you breathe is
something we have to clean up today
because it's hurting you when your kids
and your grandkids the water you drink
you saw what happened in Flint Michigan
if we start putting the tailings from
these coal mines into the rivers which
an EPA regulation just got rolled back
will now permit people downstream again
all of a sudden wake up one day and find
they've been in there kids been poisoned
this is just this romance start between
the two of you because you're two very
unlikely two different people
Mike you said you're not your
stereotypical environmentalists you said
you don't we're broken starts and eat
granola
and when he was mayor he had a great
idea and a great idea was to get better
financing for mass transit in New York
City and he asked me to help him and I
did to help and we failed the state
legislature wouldn't see the common
sense of raising enough money for
transit in New York City and at that
point we realized we were both
frustrated by the failure of the state
government in this case right now maybe
it's the federal government to do
common-sense things that mayor's just
saw as this is what I was put here to do
I hope people get how serious this is
what great did you give President Trump
at the end of a hundred days well it's
much too early to tell I can tell you if
I were him I would focus on building a
team that's going to stay with him for
his whole administration rather than
trying to get things done whatever done
in a given set of time you're never
going to satisfy enough people to do
that but if you build a real team you
can have a successful administration and
if you don't build the team you can't do
it on your own you just that's a great
for now don't like you didn't say can
office